[Musique]
bonjour à tous vous êtes bien sur lcp
public sénat c'est l'heure de parlement
hebdo l'essentiel de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec michael
annett bonjour katia bonjour à tous et
avec nous cette semaine notre invité
pierre laurent bonjour bonjour est le
secrétaire national du parti communiste
et beaucoup de questions à vous poser
cette semaine sénateur de paris
justement l'actualité on le verra c'est
la fin de la session parlementaire à
l'assemblée et au sénat
marqué par des adieux des hommages
évidemment sur fond de bilan politique
cette semaine françois bayrou a décidé
de rejoindre emmanuel macron un
ralliement sans conditions et à gauche
benoît hamon reçoit le soutien de l'ue
vers yannick jadot dialogue toujours un
peu compliqué avec jean luc mélenchon
est d'abord l'actualité parlementaire
puisque c'était la dernière séance à
l'assemblée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hommage bilan et émotion députés et
ministres se sont retrouvés une dernière
fois pour une séance de questions au
gouvernement les travaux parlementaires
sont en effet suspendus et bien c'est
l'occasion de faire un petit tour
d'horizon des principales lois votées
sous cette législature rabique à cinq
ans de discussions et plus de 400 texte
adopté par l'assemblée
l'hémicycle aura une fois de plus était
le théâtre de débats enflammés à l'image
de la loi sur le mariage pour tous vous
agrippez un ordre que vous croyait
immuables vous voulez en faire une
institution doctrine herman
conservatrice au sort ce vous agrippez
un ordre de vous croyez immuable cent
trente six heures de débat sur un sujet
qui divise dont l'hémicycle et dans la
rue le mariage des personnes de même
sexe malgré les clivages
la loi est votée et entre en vigueur au
printemps 2013 autre pomme de discorde
la loi macron qui réforme le travail du
dimanche la justice prud'homale ou
encore les règles de licenciement
collectif
je salue ici l'entousiasme qui sur tous
les bancs continuera à accueillir ces
travaux parce que puisque tout le monde
et pour la réforme et le déblocage de
l'économie nous irons face au socialiste
frondeurs qui jugent le texte trop
libéral manuel valls passe en force en
utilisant l'armé du 49 3
cet outil législatif permet au
gouvernement de faire passer une loi
sans vote
je ne prendrai pas la responsabilité du
risque d'un rejet d'un tel projet moins
d'un an plus tard la bataille
parlementaire reprend sur la loi elle
comme riz du nom de la ministre du
travail et du dialogue social
là encore manuel valls peine à
rassembler sa majorité
il utilise le 49-3 à trois reprises les
frondeurs les écologistes et les
communistes en train de déposer une
motion de censure
en vain cette 14e législature aura aussi
été marquée par les attaques terroristes
décrétée au lendemain du massacre du
bataclan du 13 novembre 2015 l'état
d'urgence a été très largement voté par
les députés ce régime d'exception
renouveler cinq fois a été dénoncée par
les écologistes et le front de gauche
pour
la restriction de liberté pendant cinq
ans l'assemblée aura siégé pendant plus
de cinq mille deux cents heures et les
la séance publique a aussi était
suspendu au sénat pierre laurent si vous
ne deviez garder qu'un seul texte
emblématique de cette législature en
tout cas de ces cinq ans vous retiendrez
lequel je crois que la seule la seule
loi de progrès qui a été réellement voté
dans le quinquennat et le mariage pour
tous et d'ailleurs il ya eu beaucoup de
manifestations et on voit que cette loi
s'applique dans le rassemblement des
français et sans susciter les drames que
certains nous annonçait au contraire
cette loi est très accepter tout se
passe très bien dans le pays on a fait
progresser le droit et l'égalité avec
cette loi
par ailleurs évidemment ce que je
retiens c'est l'accumulation de textes
dont les principes ont été adoptés par
le 49-3 la loi macro et la loi elle
comrie qui au contraire ont détricoté de
manière très inquiétante les droits
sociaux et je me réjouis qu'il y ait
maintenant un dialogue entre les forces
de gauche et écologistes pour revenir
sur ces loi de régression sociale en
tant que parlementaire vous estimez
qu'il ya trop de lois qu'on a trop
légiférer que ce travail est trop long
c'est ce que françois hollande a essayé
de dire pendant cinq ans au ciré de la
réforme sont venus à l'assemblée comme
au sénat
non mais le problème c'est que au
légifère mal d'abord il ya un problème
de représentation dans l'assemblée
nationale vous savez que nous sommes
favorables nous à la proportionnelle
parce qu'on a une assemblée qui n'est
pas à ses représentants se nomme
l'intégrale ou avec une dose de
proportionnelle
parce que il faut il qu'ils nous avons
besoin d'une assemblée qui soit
représentatif de l'ensemble de la
société française
elle ne l'est pas suffisamment premier
problème deuxièmement nous ne passons
pas assez temps non pas dans l'hémicycle
et les commissions mais nous ne passons
pas assez de temps à discuter avec la
société française et le temps
législatives devraient un temps où la
dimension démocratique du débat citoyen
soit plus importante et enfin
l'initiative législative ne revient pas
assez aux députés aux sénateurs et à la
société est trop au seul gouvernement
petite question comme ça pendant cette
législature la transparence a été quand
même renforcé avec des
règles et des lois nouvelles est-ce que
la sphère fillon de présumés emplois
fictifs a tout remis en cause où il ya
quand même un progrès dans ce domaine la
réalisation il ya eu quelques progrès
mais on est on est encore loin du compte
on sait qu'il ya des sujets roux l'a vu
avec la faire de l' embauche de membres
de sa famille par l'état comme assistant
parlementaire
il faut sûrement renforcer les
réglementations pour empêcher il ya des
choses encore plus sérieuses le
renforcement de la lutte contre les
conflits contre les conflits d'intérêts
il ya trop de proximité entre une partie
des responsables politiques et les
milieux de l'argent le milieu des
affaires de visa à régler ce problème là
avec un registre
oui mais il y a les choses qui progresse
mais elle progresse lentement et georges
en revient à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure je crois que plus
fondamentalement pour régler ce problème
il faut qu'on change la représentation
parlementaire
si on avait davantage d'ouvriers
davantage d'employés davantage de
salariés comme tout le monde et qu'on
leur donnait la possibilité grâce à un
statut de l'élu d'exercer un mandat puis
de retourner dans la vie professionnelle
en est on des garanties de revenus et
d'emplois eh bien on oxygène ray la vie
politique et c'est cela que je touche
mon cas mais rythme les deux chambres
assemblée sénat avec le même rôle pour
le sénat où jean je crois qu'il ya des
choses à faire évoluer là aussi est en
fait le sénat le sénat pour être
transformé il faut élire les deux
sénateurs et et le sénat je crois
devrait transformer pour devenir une
assemblée plus représentatif des élus
locaux ce qu'elle est mais aussi de la
société reed du champ oui des
territoires et aussi probablement de
l'ensemble des représentants de la
société civile comme on dit aujourd'hui
donc je pense qu'on pourrait réfléchir à
une évolution de la composition du sénat
alors on va revenir à la politique et la
campagne présidentielle cette semaine un
homme a créé la surprise
[Musique]
surprise parce que françois bayrou à
renoncer finalement se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle le président
du modem a décidé de soutenir
emmanuel macron voit tout cela avec
stéphanie des pierres pour la première
fois en 15 ans françois bayrou ne
participera pas à la course à l'elysée
il tend la main à emmanuel macron parce
que le risque est immense parce que les
français sont désorientés et souvent
désespérés j'ai décidé de faire à
emmanuel macron une offre d'alliance
après avoir dénoncé les affaires fillon
françois bayrou joue donc la carte du
rassemblement avec un homme qu'il
critiquait il y encore quelques semaines
pour le maire de pau ce n'est pas un
ralliement mais une proposition
d'alliance et sous conditions il veut
que le programme d' emmanuel macron
inclut une loi de moralisation de la vie
publique pour lutter d'abord contre les
conflits d'intérêts très vite emmanuel
macron confirme qu'il accepte l'offre de
françois bayrou on ce bayrou a proposé
cette alliance sur des principes clairs
qui rejoignent d'ailleurs les valeurs de
notre mouvement dans marche dans
lesquelles je me retrouve et que je suis
donc prêt à porter c'est pourquoi j'ai
accepté cette proposition et je me
réjouis
ce faisant qu'il puisse accompagner le
travail qui est le nôtre avec ses
spécificités avait des valeurs qu'il
porte avec l'histoire du centre qu'ils
peuvent
les deux hommes doivent se rencontrer
aujourd'hui ce coup de théâtre dans la
campagne fait vivement réagir à droite
comme à gauche
monsieur bayrou est fidèle à lui même
c'est un expert en trahisons en
compromission il a toute sa carrière
politique trail toute sa carrière
politique il s'est vendu au plus offrant
les électeurs de droite ils ont
passé françois bayrou par pertes et
profits en 2012
lorsqu'il les a trahis et aujourd'hui
françois bayrou il prend des électeurs à
gauche et non pas des électeurs à droite
je crois que c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour monsieur fillon je crois
que françois bayrou savait qu'il n'avait
lui-même aucune chance de parvenir au
deuxième tour et là il rend service à
quelqu'un emmanuel macron qui est
capable d'accéder au deuxième tour
ce nouveau duo macro bayrou
convaincra-t-il les électeurs réponse
dans tout juste deux mois au premier
tour de la présidentielle
bienheureux je voudrais vous proposer
une image regarder on va la regarder
ensemble
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette union
c'est très simple les masques tombent
françois bayroux poursuit le projet
politique qui a été le sien depuis 15
ans créer un centre droit destiné
ensuite une fois qu'il sera constituée à
s'allier et à voter des projets libéraux
avec la droite parce que c'est cette
c'est de cela dont il s'agit d'ailleurs
avant de se rallier à un maquereau
béraud a envisagé une alliance avec
alain juppé qui finalement n'a pas été
le candidat de la droite
donc ils essayent de constituer un
centre droit et le programme que
commence à dévoiler avec plus de
précision emmanuel macron confirme ce
que je suis en train de dire 60
milliards d'économies soit 5 milliards
d'économies sur les dépenses
cent vingt mille fonctionnaires
supprimés voilà c'est un espère coiffer
ses du cc du fion en modèle réduit
mais en vérité tout cela avance dans la
même dans la même direction
les filles ont été réduits ça veut dire
qu'il prend exemple sur françois fait
c'est là dans le même sens la même
lignée libéral on poursuit on continue
de s'attaquer aux grands
aux grands acquis de notre modèle social
vont le faire a dit lisant je veux citer
une enquête qui a été publié hier très
officiellement la commande publique
c'est à dire les investissements publics
qui permettent de créer de l'emploi etc
entre 2012 et 2017 a baissé de 24
milliards d'euros
ça c'est le résultat des politiques a
inspiré emmanuel macron c'est ceux qui
tirent tout vers le bas et en
particulier les équipements publics
parce que ceux qui souffrent il ya une
autre proposition qu'il a formulé ce
vendredi matin 10 milliards de baisses
d'impôts field et élus notamment sur
l'exonération des impôts locaux 80 % des
français seraient exonérées de cet impôt
locaux oui mais vous ne dites pas tout
parce que le problème est de voir la
vision globale du problème aujourd'hui
c'est quoi les impôts des français les
impôts des français le premier impôts
des français on n'en parle jamais c'est
la tva et de très loin
l'impôt le plus un jeune ne veut pas là
il ne va pas y toucher or ça il y a il
ya une pression énorme pour augmenter
ses impôts les manuels mais il est pas
très clair sur cette question parce
qu'il dit aussi qu'il veut respecter les
engagements et les directives
européennes qui demandent l'augmentation
qu'ils augmentent qui demandent
l'augmentation de la tva donc à sa
personne ne soit touché alors qu'il
faudrait faire baisser ses impôts de tva
qui sont les impôts les plus injustes et
ensuite ils haug il il exonère dans ses
propositions
une grande partie du capital et ensuite
il dit je vais donner un peu plus d'un
autre côté mais comme ils l'auront des
classes moyennes dans le coeur du
réacteur ça devrait quand même vous
séduire cette norme et ça c'est un
discours c'est le discours qu'on a
entendu pendant tout le quinquennat
qu'on entendait sous sarkozy mais la
réalité des politiques qui sont qui sont
mises en oeuvre et qui continuent de
figurer dans le programme des manuels
macro c'est une pression accrue au total
quand on met tout bon t'as beau et qu'on
refait les comptes et qu'on regarde le
sol
c'est une pression accrue sur les plus
modestes et les couches moyennes via les
programmes vers le rendre il ya aussi
les les personnalités est ce que vous
pensez que cette image françois bayrou
emmanuel macron cette image dudus du
centre qui essaye de se réunir peut
créer une nouvelle dynamique et peut
changer un peu la donne aussi par
rapport à vous mets à votre
positionnement qu'il y est il peut y
avoir des dynamiques
caron faveur de lille en a une en faveur
de l'extrême droite et il y en a une en
faveur il peut y en avoir une en faveur
de macrobe roues mais ce n'est pas parce
qu'il ya une dynamique que moi je veux
m'extasier devant cette dynamique si
elle est porteuse d'un projet si elle
est porteuse d'un projet s'il ya des
cartes d'un projet qui fait qui fait
reculer le pays
je continuerai de la combattre je pense
qu'il y a un travail d'explication
il ya énormément de comme un de yahia
autour d' emmanuel macron une comme
incroyable pour le faire passer comme
quelqu'un de porteur de solutions
nouvelles
en vérité il a été puisque vous parliez
du coeur de rector dans le coeur du
réacteur du quinquennat de françois
hollande ça a été un des idées aux
héritiers de françois leurs idéologues
de ceux de ce quinquennat et il veut
maintenant poursuivre dans cette
direction alors cette fois ci en
s'affranchissant totalement de tout
engagement de gauche et c'est pour ça
qu'il s'allierait n'est pas l'arrivée de
françois hollande
il est ici il continue dans la même
direction mais en tirant encore
davantage le bateau vers la balance et
allez on va parler un petit peu de la
gauche après on va parler surtout des
alliances des ralliements et puis des
mouvements aussi
[Musique]
et on va commencer avec jean luc
mélenchon il était l'invité d'une
émission politique jeudi soir notamment
sur france 2 et jean luc mélenchon
laisse la porte ouverte à une discussion
écoutez le voilà comment les choses vont
se passer je suis pris vendredi midi
parce que je déjeune avec pierre laurent
dans le faire le point comme nous le
faisons régulièrement
samedi c'est la journée écologique sur
le livret écologie donc je serais pris
toute la journée mais je suis d'accord
dimanche ou lundi s'il le veut pour le
rencontrer
je veux pas simplement parce que me dire
tiens mélenchon pour toi y'a 30
circonscriptions dont 10 gagnable je
m'en fous je à mon âge j'ai fait pas une
carrière et vous savez c'est dur parce
que les gens qui avec moi ils détestent
tellement le ps maintenant ils les
déteste tellement que c'est moi qui dois
dire doucement du calme
si vous obtenez les garanties que vous
demandez à benoît hamon est ce que vous
êtes prêt à retirer votre candidature
pourquoi il a retiré la palud et bien
voilà on en est là qui retire à sa
candidature
ça ne peut pas fonctionner non je crois
qu'il fallait il faut commencer par moi
je suis favorable à des discussions à
des rencontres et jean luc mélenchon a
laissé cette porte ouverte il a même
fait une proposition et ces rencontres
doivent porter sur le contrat de
majorité c'est à dire sur les
engagements communs ce qu'attendent les
français ce sont des engagements clairs
moi je crois qu'à quatre questions que
je souhaite voir discuter la première
c'est nous allons abroger la loi une
connerie par quoi nous la remplaçons moi
je crois qu'il faut deux grands piliers
sociaux une loi de sécurisation de
l'emploi et de la formation et et pas
dubé risation mail au contraire et une
relance de la sécurité sociale le
deuxième point c'est qu'il faut
reprendre le pouvoir sur l'argent pour
lutter contre la finance donc il faut
s'occuper de la fiscalité de l'évasion
fiscale s'occuper des banques s'occuper
de l'argent qu'on donne aux entreprises
pas comme on a fait avec le cic au
troisièmement il faut la 6ème république
avec des mesures précises dont la
proportionnelle dont je parlais tout à
l'heure
et là il ya beaucoup de ce soir est là
à mouthe points communs entre nous donc
ça doit pouvoir avancer et quatrièmement
il faut articuler la question de la
transition écologique et d'une nouvelle
industrialisation la frayeur ce cas des
sections réalisation de la france pour
le moment j'en entends pas bon qu'à
parler donc vous êtes drôles et dispos à
gauche donc je pense qu'il faut
éclaircir non par exemple sur la
question de la finance il ya beaucoup de
choses à éclaircir
c'est les questions dont j'entends peu
peut parler pour le moment qu'est ce
qu'on va faire et qui ont une mauvaise
dollar sur les bancs et noir à tout le
monde et à benoît hamon en particulier
j'ai d'ailleurs invité mois l'ensemble
des forces de gauche
j'espère qu'il y aura des rencontres
peut-être même d'ici là mardi 28 février
un débat à la bellevilloise à paris sur
ce thème
l'ennemi c'est toujours la finance et
donc puisque cet engagement n'a pas été
tenus par françois hollande qu'est ce
que nous ferons demain pour le tenir ces
paris benoît hamon vienne 28 février
je rencontre benoît hamon année c'est
que pascal cherki leur présenterai à
cette rencontre belloy moumoute été
façonnée gauche françaises soumises
l'esl et le l'équipe de benoit mots à et
les europe ecologie les verts seront
présents david cormand le secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts
m'a répondu favorablement au noirmont
vous invite dans la discussion avec
pierre laurent et yannick jadot
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à y aller
mais bien sûr que je suis disponible jeu
il ça fait un an que je demande que ces
discussions aient lieu jeudi depuis le
départ que nous aurions dû démarrer par
la discussion sur le contrat de majorité
au lieu de s'engager dans la
multiplication de candidatures donc je
dis que nous devons avancer sur cette
question parce que ceux qui bute encore
aujourd'hui même si les choses bougent
ce n'est pas d'abord la question de
candidature c'est la clarté du contrat
de majorité que nous pouvons passer
ensemble et je pense que nous plus avoir
tant mieux peu importe que ce soit à mon
ou mélenchon mais prenons les choses
dans l'ordre c'est parce qu'on ne les
prend pas dans l'ordre la question des
hommes armés l'ont jamais moi je ne fais
pas de cette question un préalable mais
je dis que compensé jeudi que pour
avancer il faut avancer sur une question
la clarté des engagements que nous
prenons
parce que c'est ça qui fera notre créé
ibilité face à nos adversaires
politiques et aux yeux des français qui
attendent des réponses précises et
aujourd'hui on n'a aucun délai ne soit
retiré sa candidature je regretterais
les croyances on l'a bien dit il on doit
retirer sa candidature mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'il retirerait sa candidature
quoi vous nous avons retiré cette
discussion n'a pas commencé et que nous
ne sommes pas d'accord encore sur les
engagements de campagne
donc il faut que les campagnes des uns
et des autres s'amplifie qu'elle
mobilise le maximum d'électeurs de
gauche que tout le monde continue sa
campagne et la mène et que ces
discussions s'intensifient à poux à vous
entendre
l'équation est simple c'est l'unité ou
la défaite de la gauche c'est simple
mais c'est ce que je dis pas ce que je
dis c'est ce que je dis depuis depuis
depuis un an donc je suis constant
transparent déterminer sur cette
question et jeudi que l'unité c'est
l'unité sur un pacte d'engagement clair
aux yeux des français qui nous donnera
réellement les moyens de mener demain
une politique de changement parce que
vous savez les français il écoute tout
ça mais eux ce qu'ils veulent savoir
c'est si demain si nous appliquons telle
ou telle politique la vie changera
vraiment des promesses ils ont entendu
ils ont entendu beaucoup en 2012
ils ont entendu pendant tout le
quinquennat des gens leur expliquer
pendant qu'ils votaient des lois de
régression sociale que tout ça était
magnifique pour le progrès social
donc ils en ont soupé des discours on
leur raconte pourquoi je vous entends
très bien sûr tous âges à l'euro oui
mais c'est en vous attend il est très
clair que vous simplement il ya des
français aoc qui se pose une question ce
qu'ils vont voter pour une personnalité
qu'est ce qui fera que même si tous les
engagements que vous proposez sont
signés sur sur la table sur une faille
on choisira l'un ou l'autre mais c'est
ce qui fera la différence
si on parvient à sa nounou cette
question vous savez elle se résoudre à
assez facilement à ces face à wallers
messi parce que c'est pour le moment il
mais cette discussion vous me dites
une fois qu'on aura réglé ça mais le
problème c'est que pour le moment
personne ne sait encore miata autour de
la table pour le faire donc s'apprécier
rien n'est signé sait rien n'est réglé
il leur ado candidat invention nous
avancions dans la vie réelle sur ça et
ensuite on traitera les eaux rien n'est
réglé ses vannes ira la guerre y aura de
candidats parler de ça et pas d'autres
choses
c'est la garantie pour avancer il faut
parler du faux et pas d'autres choses ni
de sani des législatives et du reste il
faut parler de ça et quand on aura
résolu ce problème vous verrez que les
autres questions pour voir ce que vous
ne pensez pas quand même que ces petits
jeux d'appareils de négociation si on
peut dire mais c'est vous qui disiez ses
longueurs - négociations cet attentisme
et puissent fatiguer un peu certains
électeurs mais bien sûr mais déçoit
parfois mais c'est vous qui parlez de
jeu de moi je dis au contraire il ne
faut pas des jeux d'appareil
moi je demande en plus que cette
discussion et les lieux publiquement moi
je suis c'est pour ça que j'organise un
nra compliquer à la bellevilloise
je pense qu'il faut que nous menions ce
débat devant les citoyens devant les
français donc moi je ne demande pas
d'aidé des marchandages l'appareil je
veux exactement le contraire
je veux des engagements clairs
transparents pris devant les français
alors justement d'écouter ce que disait
à ce sujet benoît hamon ce vendredi sur
france télévisions à côté j'ai
aujourd'hui la le rassemblement vous
vous rendez compte
depuis 74 l'écologie politique avait un
candidat ça n'est pas rien le choix
qu'ils font de dire aujourd'hui le
candidat de l'écologie politique c'est
benoît hamon voilà le choix qu'ils font
c'est un immense honneur pour moi je le
dis un immense honneur au moins une très
grande responsabilité et c'est pour ça
que je me tourne quand jean-luc
mélenchon s'adresse à moi avec beaucoup
de respect vers les électeurs qui sont
ceux de jean luc mélenchon est ce qu'il
ya une dynamique quand même en faveur de
benoît hamon avec ce rallye mende
yannick jadot qui a quand même était là
donc est-ce que vous salue et déjà ce
geste
yannick jadot est ce que c'est que ça
peut créer ou bossus sur le
le geste qu'ils viennent de faire jaton
comme tout le monde de lire le contenu
puisque je dis que c'est monaco
vous demandez à le voir on a eu quand je
suis comme tout le monde je ne vais pas
lui est-ce que vous je ne l'aimé tant
que partenaire va s'objecter devoirs et
n'a pas été rendu public donc c'est la
première chose à faire puisque je dis
moi il faut parler des questions de
concurrence intègre un loup jeu non je
ne dis rien je dis que je souhaite lire
ce texte puis pour pour savoir de quoi
de quoi on parle
bon et puis ce que si une rencontre
devient possible
eh bien nous en parlerons tous ensemble
et comme tout le monde va venir à la
rencontre que j'organise le 28 on pourra
aussi en parler publiquement c'est pour
ça c'est important d'en parler
publiquement parce que ça aide à ce que
les choses se rencontraient possible il
est bien sûr mais moi je le souhaite je
veux vivre pour ça et je pense
franchement ce vendredi oui bien sûr
mais je répète c'est je n'ai pas besoin
de lui dire puisque lui même a dit hier
soir qu'il ne fermait pas la porte à une
une rencontre donc moi je crois que la
dynamique se créera si les gens je le
répète si les gens sont qu' il y as sur
la table des propositions qui vont
changer leur vie c'est sûr ça qu'il y a
une grande défiance vous entendu sur
progresser et c'est sur cette question
qu'il faut répondre
alors voyons un peu plus dans les
détails pierre laurens que changer
éventuellement ce ralliement voyons
notamment l'état des lieux des positions
au sein de votre parti notamment pour
les législatives le parti communiste
français lance une bouteille à la mer
avec un tract distribué aujourd'hui à
plusieurs millions d'exemplaires
il appelle les candidats de la gauche à
reprendre et intensifier les discussions
pour trouver enfin un accord majoritaire
parce qu'il ya péril en la demeure car
c'est quoi le visage de la france si on
va vers le second tour marine le pen
fillon quelle est la france de derrière
d'après elle est pas belle à voir
le pcf a choisi jean luc mélenchon comme
candidat mais certains de ses membres
semblent fatigués des derniers échanges
où manquent des changes entre le leader
de la france insoumise et benoît hamon
je pense que ça doit créer dans le pays
pour ceux qui se reconnaissent dans les
valeurs de gauche
beaucoup de déception pas mal de
désarroi ya beaucoup de gens qui
devraient se dire mais arrêtez avec tous
c'est bon ça fait parfois un peu bac à
sable la direction du pcf en dose donc
le rôle de médiateur et prévoit de
rencontrer prochainement les équipes des
trois candidats un appel à l'unité qui
pourrait aussi être un appel du pied en
vue des élections législatives
ce que j'espère pour ma part qu aux
puces au moins travailler sur des
convergences idéologiques sur des
convergences de deux propositions
et dire que demain peut-être que demain
on pourra voir quoi qu'il en soit une
majorité de parlementaires qui porte un
socle commun pour l'élection
présidentielle pour l'instant le mot
d'ordre est de rester derrière jean-luc
mélenchon alors piano et nous resterons
maîtres démission le mouvement jean luc
mélenchon a donc investi des candidats
pour les législatives face au vôtre
alors que vous lui apportez votre
soutien ce que ce n'est pas un peu une
provocation
est ce que vous allez lui apporter vos
parrainages je crois que cette cette
question et tenteront d'avancer
donc nous avons eu une réunion hier sur
ça il ya des choses qui ne vont pas du
tout de ce point de vue là nous l'avons
je les dis à jean luc mélenchon et je
continuerai de lui dire si si les
difficultés persistent et revenant bien
sûr très fermement
mais nous avançons nous avançons ce qui
est certain sur ça pour moi les choses
sont simples c'est que pour mener une
politique de changement un il faut une
majorité parlementaire
elle sera forcément diverses elle ne
sera pas le résultat d'une seule famille
politique de la gauche
et deuxièmement dans cette majorité
parlementaire il faut des députés
communistes et du front de gauche bien
plus nombreux qu'en dehors il y aura
toujours un bien ou plus nombreux qu'en
encore plus fort dans une raison très
simple c'est que quand on regarde ce qui
s'est passé depuis cinq ans qui a été
fidèle à ses engagements à gauche et
bien un seul groupe
celui là donc il sera tous donnant à
chaque fois qu'il y aura un député
communiste ou du front de gauche de plus
les français seront une chose c'est que
tiendront lançant je vous entends bien
c'est pas de candidat de la france face
aux mises face à des candidats
communistes façade et notamment celles
exigences minimum à des candidats
communistes sortants
parce qu'ils ont fait la preuve de leur
fidélité aux engagements de gauche donc
pourquoi aller présenter une candidature
de concurrence et face à ce que nous
pouvons regagner que nous avons perdu
en 2012 et qui sont en situation de
reconquête aujourd'hui ça c'est
évidemment l'exigence minimum ensuite
nous nous sommes prêts à travailler
pauvre pour contribuer à l'élection de
nouveaux députés communistes et du front
de gauche et deux députés de la france
insoumise bien évidemment vous si vous
ouvrez là par toutes les familles de la
gauche doivent progresser et doivent
progresser ensemble en s'épaulant les
unes les autres et à commencer par
celles qui ont le même candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
c'est quand même le bon sens donc je
crois que le bon sens qui est qui est le
nôtre dans cette affaire va finir par
l'emporter et est d'ores et déjà dans
les circonscriptions en question que je
visite pour aller soutenir les candidats
très comprise par les électeurs de
gauche et des électeurs du front
j'avais une question sur les plus petits
candidats aujourd'hui qu'ils sont ce
qu'on appelle à l'extrême gauche je
pense à nathalie arthaud 1 philippe
poutou
ils ont des difficultés pour recueillir
leurs parrainages
est-ce que vous avez les aider non nous
nous où nous nous avons un candidat
nous le soutenons et vous avez là mais
nous nous distribuions panneaux non
parrainage comme ça donc
nous soutenons un candidat nous avons
des exigences normales et c'est à cela
que nous consacrons nos efforts nous
n'allons pas disperser ça n'a pas de
sens
après il ya un grand problème vous savez
la candidature global avec ce système de
l'élection présidentielle ce système de
parrainage vous savez très bien que dans
nos propositions pour la 6ème république
nous on veut changer beaucoup de choses
pour sortir de la présidentialisation de
la vie politique mais il faut pas nous
demander à nous d'assumer toutes les
mauvaises toutes les mauvaises règles de
ce système et le débat qu'on en entend
parler de ce débat notamment sur tf1 des
grands des grands candidats débat oui ça
ça pose à vous a surpris
non mais ça pose un problème
effectivement mais vous savez contre une
loi récente qui justement a modifié à
supprimer la période d'égalité de temps
de parole qui est il et c'est un vrai
sujet démocratique qui est qui est un
des nombreux problèmes posés par la
présidentialisation excessive de la vie
politique merci beaucoup merci père
laurent très bonne heure s'ils avaient
tous trois types de programmes sur lcp
public sénat
j'aime
[Musique]